what is your strategy coming into this
event I mean I think Strad should always
be a win for those of us who have done
quite well the incentive to try and
finish in say the top two or three is
it's really strong so we do really well
in the rapid and blitz I think it's most
likely that it will qualify for London
without having to worry about the
classical event everyone wants to
qualify for London tournament right now
there are like five players in a very
close race fighting for that fourth spot
I'm close to to the qualifying spots so
the first event is very very important
if I will manage to play very well in
represent please and then probably I'll
have good chances to to be in top 40 my
situation is still was a comfortable
area and force with two points margin so
that's alright but basically the idea
would be to secure my my spot a bit more
coming into the classic well I will try
to reflect on some of the things that
went wrong in Paris 11 but you don't
want to depress yourself too much also
so hopefully I'll just try to make for a
fresh start out of it I mean I did very
poorly in my last two events
I really couldn't pretty much couldn't
have done worse I kind of carried over
and done to my confidence from one event
to come into the other but I can still
do well here and I can still play well
and I don't really think I should worry
too much of that past results it's great
for me because I don't get so many
opportunities to test myself against the
very top again and thankful for the
opportunity and I hope that I can prove
that I'm worthy of the invitation and
the very important tournaments of course
and I will just try to show my best play
first time in US and centuries